opens for you now at the party's Shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
joins us now live from Central uh London
I'm Keen to talk to you about a whole
range of issues including strikes but
just to pick up on something we were
just talking about with Siobhan and the
interview just there she was saying that
there's no point about talking about
getting people back into the workplace
without talking about child care and you
want to guaranteed child care don't you
for all parents of children aged between
nine months to 11 years how would that
work
well we have been listening to business
and parents about what's holding them
back and what's holding back our economy
and that does involve making sure that
we've got a modern child care system
that reflects the needs of parents and
children and how they live their lives
today so we are looking at how we
fundamentally rethink how we deliver
child care in our country so from the
end of Parental leave right through to
the end of primary school and the first
step we've set out around that is making
sure we deliver breakfast clubs for all
primary school children in England
because it's important that we get the
early years right and we'll have more to
say on that but also parents know that
their child care problems don't end when
their children start at school and so
many women and sadly women in particular
that I speak to are giving up jobs they
love or are cutting back on their hours
because child care just isn't there and
it's holding back our economy if you're
serious about growth you've got to be
serious about delivering a modern child
care system too you know what I'm going
to have to Pivot very quickly because
we've had some breaking news through and
you will understand when you hear what
that news is we've heard from the UK
prime minister on Nadeem zahawi and if
you remember he's asked his at advisor
to look into whether or not the
doomsahari broke the ministerial code in
relation to his tax Affairs he's put out
a statement where he says it's clear
that there has been a serious breach of
the ministerial code he says as a result
I've informed you of my decision to
remove you from your position in
government so that there is a letter
from the prime minister to Nadim zahawi
saying that he has been removing him
from government so he's effectively in
sacked from the government because it is
clear to the Prime Minister there has
been a breach of the ministerial code
I'm going to bring you the full letters
just as soon as I can but Bridget
Phillips and what's your immediate
reaction to that
well it's not clear to me what the Prime
Minister has been waiting for it's been
as plain as day for weeks now that this
was going to be the outcome but because
I wish you soon acts weakness his
weakness within his own party and his
failure to put the country first as a
result it's taken a very long time to
get here it's just a shame it's taken
him so long that our country continues
to be sucked into this mire of sleaze
that the conservatives are delivering
for us and you know when Rishi soon that
first became Prime and as she promised
us about integrity and accountability I
think we're a very very long way away
from that
uh just to bring you a bit more details
from the full letter that we have now
got this letter from the prime minister
to Nadeem zahari dated today he says
when I became prime minister last year I
pledged that the government I lead would
have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level that is
why following new information which came
to light in recent days regarding your
personal financial arrangements and
decorations I asked the Laurie Magnus
the independent advisor and Minister's
interests to fully investigate this
matter you agreed and undertook to
cooperate fully with the inquiry
following the completion of the
independent advisors investigation the
findings of which he has shared with us
both it is clear that there has been a
serious breach of the ministerial codes
as a result I've informed you of my
decision to remove you from your
position in his Majesty's government he
goes on to say that Nadeem zahari should
be extremely proud of his achievements
over the five years referencing the
vaccine procurement program program in
particular and the fact that he is a
kurdish-born Iraqi Refugee that's
something which people up and down this
country have rightly valued uh Rishi
Cena says in this letter but just to sum
summarize it is clear this morning that
the investigation has completed uh into
Nadim zahawi the findings have been
shared with both the Prime Minister and
Nadeem zahawi himself and as a result
the uh Rishi soon at the Prime Minister
says it's clear there has been a serious
breach of the ministerial code and as a
result he has been sacked from the
government
let's go back shall we to Bridget
Phillipson and you say that it's taken
the Prime Minister a long time to reach
this conclusion has it the um
investigation was uh was finalized
pretty quickly and as soon as the
results came in he's gone
he didn't need the advisor to tell him
this and it's just not clear to me why
it's taken so long but the sad truth is
that Nadeem zahawi is one of a number of
cases that we've seen in recent months
in the conservative parties I also look
forward to the Prime Minister taking
action against Dominic Robb and I also
look forward to the Prime Minister
taking action against Zoella brathman
who herself was found to have broken the
ministerial Court rather than Zachary
invited her back into government I mean
it is just a joke for the prime minister
to suggest that somehow this is a
government that has got integrity and
accountability at his heart they are
Riven with sleeves they're just fighting
it out constantly amongst themselves and
it's the British people who suffer as a
result because it's all about the
conservative party and it's not about
what's right for our country we face
really big challenges right now but when
you've got this constant infighting and
when you've got a prime minister that is
so weak he can't stand up for what's
right and he kind of outsources that
judgment to others I think it tells you
everything you need to know about really
why it is time for a change in Britain
you know you say he's weak but he has
just sacked Nadeem zahawi uh this
morning after getting the evidence
through I guess those people I mean he
really had
already had no choice but to sucker but
he should have sacked him weeks ago I
mean it was always going to end in this
way
um so you know why on Earth aren't we
also seeing action on Zoella bravaman
and Dominic Robin you know all the
Scandal that continues to envelop Boris
Johnson This Is Not Just One Bad Apple
this is right at the heart of the
conservative party and it speaks to the
prime minister's weakness and and his
weak position within his own party that
as a result he can't put the country
first
um do you think that there was an
argument that some close to Rishi Cena
might make that he is effectively doing
a cleanup job from administrations that
have gone uh before him he wasn't told
the full facts by Nadine zahawi uh he
claims and also of course the Boris
Johnson allegations that you uh referred
to he would argue I guess that those are
more of a hangover from the previous
administration that he is now having to
deal with the consequences of
well he's sort of doing a very good job
at cleaning it up if this is what he's
claiming because you know the stench of
sleeves just hangs around the
conservative party you know yes nadeem's
a Harley but so many of them
um and I just I think it speaks to a
wider problem that you've had a
government that's been in charge now for
13 years which is ample time to build a
better Britain and rather than focusing
on what the British people want right
now they're just mired in this kind of
infighting and constant you know
problems that they face within their own
party I think politics is about
delivering for the British people right
now with the conservatives that isn't
what people are getting you know an NHS
on its knees our schools often many of
them crumbling in a terrible data that
the government refuses to publish about
the state of our schools growth at a
terrible level and so many people held
back I think Britain's besties really do
lie ahead of us but I don't see how we
get to that stronger and better position
as a country with Rishi sonaka's prime
minister with the fundamental weakness
right at the heart of his government
at the same time um you know as we were
talking before nadeem's a hobby has been
actually mentioned uh Dominic Robb the
allegations into him are being looked
into and it is right that due process
has followed in these uh very important
matters is it not
look there is just so much here of
course and you know due processes
followed in the Nadeem Sahari case and
due process has resulted in what we all
knew was going to happen in the first
place I think it speaks to the prime
minister's character and his judgment
that he hasn't been prepared to act
until now he doesn't need to wait for
other people to tell him what to do he's
the Prime Minister for goodness sake he
should just get on with it
he says uh just to recap here the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak has effectively
sacked Nadeem zahawi from a government
he's asked him he has said that he's
decided to remove him from his position
in the government because it is clear in
his words that there's been a serious
breach of the ministerial code that the
letter from Rishi sunak to Nadeem zahawi
over his tax Affairs
um do you think that with all of the
scrutiny of this story that politicians
should have to publish their tax returns
I think the trouble with all of this and
partly by I think in some in a bizarre
kind of way it suits the government is
it makes all politicians look as bad as
one another and I think there is a real
risk that it undermines um faith and
politics and the ability of you know
politicians to seek to make lives better
for the people of our country and the
people that we represent I have no issue
at all with um with the publication of
tax returns when it comes to the Prime
Minister and others and Kia Stamos set
out today that he believes that the
Prime Minister the Deputy Prime Minister
and the chancellor and their respective
counterparts should publish their tax
returns I don't think that's
particularly particularly controversial
um and you know my own tax return
there's not nothing particularly
interesting for anybody to see it's it
seems to be the likes of Medina others
that have got something that they're
wanting to hide
um so you'd be happy to publish your own
at tax return I guess the other argument
for some is that it might mean that
people who've been in business or are
wealthy people maybe put off entering
Parliament
I think if you're paying your taxes
you've got nothing to worry about the
trouble is we've had people at the heart
of government including those
responsible for running our tax system
who haven't been doing what's expected
of and that's the trouble
um but I think it's reasonable in fact I
think it's a basic expectation of those
in government that they should be
following the rules that they set for
others
um I have to say one thing that I have
found quite interesting from the latter
is the very clear uh implication that
Richard sunac has sacked Nadine zahar we
here hasn't allowed him uh the space to
write his own letter of resignation or
to leave on his terms I mean do you
think this is Russia sunak uh trying to
take charge of the situation
I think he's desperately scrabbling
around after weeks of failing to act
um it was always going to come to this
we had this ludicrous spectacle at Prime
Minister's questions this week where
Rishi Suna was defending Nadine to
Harvey in effect that was never going to
be a tenable position for the Prime
Minister I think he's just underlined
his own weakness within his party that
it's taken him so long to get to this
point
uh now um we are going to stay on the
story for the rest of the program we're
talking to Sam Cates in just a minute
but I do just want to squeeze in one
final question on the education strikes
next week because I know a lot of
parents watching this program are going
to be interested to know your answer on
it schools are facing rolling strikes
from this week a teacher's right to walk
out
well like all parents I don't want bee
strikes to go ahead of course they will
be disruptive and I don't want children
to miss time in school but the reason
that they're happening is because
government ministers are refusing to
negotiate seriously and find a
settlement there's still time for these
strikes to be called off if Government
ministers are serious about getting
around the table and trying to find a
way through it but parents will also
know that teachers increasingly feel
undervalued and under-appreciated for
the brilliant work that they do that's
what they tell me when I'm out speaking
with teachers and school leaders and
over the last decade we've had a
government that hasn't taken education
seriously as a priority for our country
and that's reflected in the fact that
teachers have had real terms pay cuts
and unsurprisingly given the wider
pressures that we're seeing right now in
the economy and they come to the end of
the road so my you know my strong advice
to ministers would be the way that these
strikes are to be called off it's the
serious and proper negotiation and there
is still time so let's make it happen
and let's get to a position that
everyone can live with but right now you
know we've had five education secretary
trees in the last year a total lack of
seriousness in dealing with an issue
that's been on the horizon since the
summer so we do need to get progress
around this but it falls to ministers
and at the minute they're just blaming
others for their own failure to act
okay thank you very much uh indeed
Bridget Phillipson a rather different
interview this morning I'm sure than the
one you're expecting to have uh good to
talk